قالت هيئه الدفاع عن راشد الغنوشي رئيس
حركه النهضه ان المحكمه الابتدائيه بتونس
قضت بسجن الغنوشي مده عام واحد مع غرامه
ماليه فيما عرف بملف الطواغيت وهي الدعوه
التي تقدم بها احد عناصر النقابات الامنيه
متهم للغنوش بانه وصف الامنيين بالطواغيت
اثناء تابينه احد قيادات حركه النهضه اثر
وفاتح وتجدر الاشاره الى ان راشد الغنوشي
محال على ذمه هذه القضيه بحاله سراحه وقد
وجهت اليه تهم تتعلق بتمجيد الارهاب واكد
المحامون ان الغنوشي المسجون منذ حوالي
شهر على ذمه قضيه اخرى لم يحضر جلسه الحكم
وقد كان قرر ان يقاطع كل جلسات التحقيق
قال جبهه الخلاص الوطني في تونس ان الحكم
صادر بحق راشد الغنوشي رئيس حركه النهضه
يثبت ان السلطه لم تستطع اثبات اي اعمال
ماديه مجرمه في حقه وان لا احد من
المعارضين مهم مهما كان موقعه او انتمائه
في مامن من مصادره حريته والزج به في
السجن
واضاف جبهه الخلاص الوطني في بيان ان
الحكم على الغنوشي وايداع اكثر من عشرين
شخصيه سياسيه بالسجن دون حجه او تبرير ليس
سوى كيلتهم جزافا والانحراف بالسلطه
والقانون
واشارت الى ان سياسه القمع هي نتيجه
مباشره للانقلاب على الدستور والانفراض
بالحكم المطلق
وملاذ السلطه في وجه فشلها في معالجه
الازمه الماليه والاجتماعيه الخانقه التي
تجتازها البلاد
معنى من تونس المختار الجماعي المحامي
وعضو الهيئه الدفاع عن راشد الغنوشي اهلا
بك سيدي المختار السجن لمده عام وغرامه
ماليه ما موقف هيئه الدفاع بعد صدور هذا
الحكم
طبعا نحن لا نستغرب بصدور هذا الحكم هذا
الحكم في اطار سياق قانونيا لا يخفى على
احد بدا منذ تجين القضاء
بالغاء المجلس الاعلى للقضائي المستقل
تواصلا الى تهديد القضاه
باعفاء زملائهم المحكمه
الاداريه في ارجاع هؤلاء ثم دخلنا مرحله
تكثيف الدعاوى والشكايات ضد الاستاذ راشد
الغنوشي كنا نستشعر ونحن نحضر معه
السماعات والتحقيقات ان الامر زائل الى
محاوله تابيد قال الاستاذ الغنوشي في
السجن لذلك قرر منوب منوبون ان يقاطع
جلسات الاستنطاق والتحقيق والمحاكمه طلب
لم تتوفر فيها ادنى شروط استقلاليه
ماذا عن الخطوه القانونيه التي ستتخذونها
طبعا الخطوه القانونيه لا تختلف عن الخطوه
السياسيه لابد
سياسيه عن ظما
وتوفير المحاكمه
العاجله ولكن
البحث ان موقفنا دفاع لا يمكن
الا بعد
والنظر فيما ينتظرنا وفيما يمكن هو التحرك
في اتجاهي في اتجاهي المشكله ان الاستاذ
رجل مصر على موقفه المتمثل في مقاطعه
الجهات القضائيه والتحقيقيه والبحثيه
جميعها من الصعب ان نقنع الاستاذ الغنوشي
بالطعن في هذا الحكم لان استطعنا
بالاعتراض في هذا الحكم وهو يبقى حكم
غيابي هو اراهين حضور الاستاذ رشد الغنوشي
للمحاكمه وهذا امر صعب اذا نعتقد ان
الخطوه الضروريه يجب ان تنطلق من السلطه
السياسيه في ضمن المحاكمات العاجله واعاده
فتح ملفات الاستاذ راشد الغنوشي
اشكرك جزيل الشكر المختار الجماعه المحامي
وعضو هيئه الدفاع عن راشد الغنوشي حدثنا
من تونس الان